In the previous lecture we developed the instruction
set architecture for the Beta, the computer
system we'll be building throughout this part
of the course.
The Beta incorporates two types of storage
or memory.
In the CPU datapath there are 32 general-purpose
registers, which can be read to supply source
operands for the ALU or written with the ALU
result.
In the CPU's control logic there is a special-purpose
register called the program counter, which
contains the address of the memory location
holding the next instruction to be executed.
The datapath and control logic are connected
to a large main memory with a maximum capacity
of 2^32 bytes, organized as 2^30 32-bit words.
This memory holds both data and instructions.
Beta instructions are 32-bit values comprised
of various fields.
The 6-bit OPCODE field specifies the operation
to be performed.
The 5-bit Ra, Rb, and Rc fields contain register
numbers, specifying one of the 32 general-purpose
registers.
There are two instruction formats: one specifying
an opcode and three registers, the other specifying
an opcode, two registers, and a 16-bit signed
constant.
There three classes of instructions.
The ALU instructions perform an arithmetic
or logic operation on two operands, producing
a result that is stored in the destination
register.
The operands are either two values from the
general-purpose registers, or one register
value and a constant.
The yellow highlighting indicates instructions
that use the second instruction format.
The Load/Store instructions access main memory,
either loading a value from main memory into
a register, or storing a register value to
main memory.
And, finally, there are branches and jumps
whose execution may change the program counter
and hence the address of the next instruction
to be executed.
To program the Beta we'll need to load main
memory with binary-encoded instructions.
Figuring out each encoding is clearly the
job for a computer, so we'll create a simple
programming language that will let us specify
the opcode and operands for each instruction.
So instead of writing the binary at the top
of slide, we'll write assembly language statements
to specify instructions in symbolic form.
Of course we still have think about which
registers to use for which values and write
sequences of instructions for more complex
operations.
By using a high-level language we can move
up one more level abstraction and describe
the computation we want in terms of variables
and mathematical operations rather than registers
and ALU functions.
In this lecture we'll describe the assembly
language we'll use for programming the Beta.
And in the next lecture we'll figure out how
to translate high-level languages, such as
C, into assembly language.
The layer cake of abstractions gets taller
yet:
we could write an interpreter for say, Python,
in C and then write our application programs
in Python.
Nowadays, programmers often choose the programming
language that's most suitable for expressing
their computations, then, after perhaps many
layers of translation, come up with a sequence
of instructions that the Beta can actually
execute.
Okay, back to assembly language, which we'll
use to shield ourselves from the bit-level
representations of instructions and from having
to know the exact location of variables and
instructions in memory.
A program called the "assembler" reads a text
file containing the assembly language program
and produces an array of 32-bit words that
can be used to initialize main memory.
We'll learn the UASM assembly language, which
is built into BSim, our simulator for the
Beta ISA.
UASM is really just a fancy calculator!
It reads arithmetic expressions and evaluates
them to produce 8-bit values, which it then
adds sequentially to the array of bytes which
will eventually be loaded into the Beta's
memory.
UASM supports several useful language features
that make it easier to write assembly language
programs.
Symbols and labels let us give names to particular
values and addresses.
And macros let us create shorthand notations
for sequences of expressions that, when evaluated,
will generate the binary representations for
instructions and data.
Here's an example UASM source file.
Typically we write one UASM statement on each
line and can use spaces, tabs, and newlines
to make the source as readable as possible.
We've added some color coding to help in our
explanation.
Comments (shown in green) allow us to add
text annotations to the program.
Good comments will help remind you how your
program works.
You really don't want to have figure out from
scratch what a section of code does each time
you need to modify or debug it!
There are two ways to add comments to the
code.
"//" starts a comment, which then occupies
the rest of the source line.
Any characters after "//" are ignored by the
assembler, which will start processing statements
again at the start of the next line in the
source file.
You can also enclose comment text using the
delimiters "/*" and "*/" and the assembler
will ignore everything in-between.
Using this second type of comment, you can
"comment-out" many lines of code by placing
"/*" at the start and, many lines later, end
the comment section with a "*/".
Symbols (shown in red) are symbolic names
for constant values.
Symbols make the code easier to understand,
e.g., we can use N as the name for an initial
value for some computation, in this case the
value 12.
Subsequent statements can refer to this value
using the symbol N instead of entering the
value 12 directly.
When reading the program, we'll know that
N means this particular initial value.
So if later we want to change the initial
value, we only have to change the definition
of the symbol N rather than find all the 12's
in our program and change them.
In fact some of the other appearances of 12
might not refer to this initial value and
so to be sure we only changed the ones that
did,
we'd have to read and understand the whole
program to make sure we only edited the right
12's.
You can imagine how error-prone that might
be!
So using symbols is a practice you want to
follow!
Note that all the register names are shown
in red.
We'll define the symbols R0 through R31 to
have the values 0 through 31.
Then we'll use those symbols to help us understand
which instruction operands are intended to
be registers, e.g., by writing R1, and which
operands are numeric values, e.g., by writing
the number 1.
We could just use numbers everywhere, but
the code would be much harder to read and
understand.
Labels (shown in yellow) are symbols whose
value are the address of a particular location
in the program.
Here, the label "loop" will be our name for
the location of the MUL instruction in memory.
In the BNE at the end of the code, we use
the label "loop" to specify the MUL instruction
as the branch target.
So if R1 is non-zero, we want to branch back
to the MUL instruction and start another iteration.
We'll use indentation for most UASM statements
to make it easy to spot the labels defined
by the program.
Indentation isn't required, it's just another
habit assembly language programmers use to
keep their programs readable.
We use macro invocations (shown in blue) when
we want to write Beta instructions.
When the assembler encounters a macro, it
"expands" the macro, replacing it with a string
of text provided by in the macro's definition.
During expansion, the provided arguments are
textually inserted into the expanded text
at locations specified in the macro definition.
Think of a macro as shorthand for a longer
text string we could have typed in.
We'll show how all this works in the next
video segment.